cas jean pierre pinelli vice président
du cercle des grandes maisons corses
bonsoir jean pierre qui les lie merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors la corse qui on le rappelle
accueille chaque année quelques 3,5
millions de visiteurs soit 10 fois sa
population on imagine votre inquiétude
avez vous déjà une idée du manque à
gagner
grosso modo bande soir d'abord grosso
modo si vous voulez on aura une saison
qu'on appelle blanche
mais on aura pas de saison en réalité
puisque le manque à gagner
mais le tourisme pèse 30 points du pib
plus des effets induits donc ça veut
dire que l'accord sera lourdement
impactés
qu'attendez vous aujourd'hui du
gouvernement on n'a pas entendu des
mesures très précises sur ce point des
manuels macron peut-être que vous avez
des informations complémentaires qui ont
pu vous rassurer sur la situation des
hôtels des restaurants
peut-être aussi des cafés will à
l'intervention de du ministre le maire
ce matin apporter plus de précisions
alors il manque à la marge quelques
petits raffinements mais du moins il ya
quand même un effort de fait et surtout
dans cette crise il faut noter qu'il ya
eu quand même une une réaction très vive
de la part de l'état des du gouvernement
sur ce sujet alors une île dépendant
tard on vient de le dire au tourisme et
aux transports comment vous vous
préférez cette préparer pardon cette
saison vous avez annoncé comme saison
blanche vous avez monté je crois une
cellule de crise sur l'île de beauté
tout à fait autour du du préfet de
région il ya une cellule de crise qui
s'organisent afin de définir à la fois
la spécificité de l'île
comme vous venez de préciser lille est
surtout impacté par le transport aérien
et n'échappe à personne que le orly
qu'elle est une la plateforme
essentielle qui desservent la corse est
fermé roissy est pour nous une situation
intermédiaire et c'est à partir de ce
moment là de plus le confinement qui se
fait dans
à l'intérieur de l'avion ne permet pas
des transports une reprise du moins des
transports envisageable tout de suite
alors le 11 mai ça veut aussi dire que
les ponts du mois de mai et bien voilà
ne pourront avoir lieu de toute façon
vous lisiez pas d'avion ça aussi c'était
une déception de votre part c'est le
côté des hôteliers corps sont c'est une
décision vous comprenez écoutez on est
obligé vous savez c'est le virus qui
pilote la machine
donc quand les scientifiques ont du mal
à appréhender si vous voulez le
phénomène les politiques encore moins
mais il est évident qu'on est obligé de
se résigner et puis attendre que le
disons du moins tout ce qui est
l'appareil de santé et là on doit quand
même remercier ceux qui aujourd'hui les
professionnels de santé qui oeuvre aux
côtés au quotidien d'une part et
deuxièmement ce régime parce qu'on n'a
pas le choix alors emmanuel macron qui a
effectivement indiqué hier soir que les
cafés restaurants et hôtels
n'ouvriraient pas pour l'instant sans
donner de date
on imagine que beaucoup de
téléspectateurs ont tendu l'oreille est
ce que vous vous avez des informations
complémentaires sur la date d'ouverture
de vos hôtels notamment et des hôtels
corse nous pourrons envisager une
ouverture que quand on aura à la fois si
vous voulez le pr
le principe de l'avarié et des
protections alors que ce soit le masque
que ça soit le test ou divers
aménagements qu'on pourra du mois
organisé il
il est impossible aujourd'hui de
rassembler des dizaines de personnes
dans un lieu commun est de pouvoir vivre
comme on vivait avant donc c'est il es t
il et il est inconcevable
et puis c'est pas souhaitable non plus
donc ça veut dire que tout le secteur va
devoir se réinventer en tout cas pour
notamment pour commencer cette saison
estivale parce que on se disait qu'avec
la fermeture de l'espace schengen
les français notamment viendrait
peut-être davantage encore resterait en
tout cas en france ça veut dire qu'il va
falloir réadapter peut-être s'attendre à
des vacances différentes
oui vous le savez on n'aura pas
d'étrangers la haye les étrangers ps 30%
sur le tourisme en corse après il ya le
tourisme je dirais nationale et là je
pense qu'à la sortie de cette crise peut
être que les français ont d'autres
priorités
d'une part et ont peut-être besoin de se
ressourcer en famille avec les amis
alors ça va se compliquer tout ça nous
n'avons pas si vous venez de clientèle
domestique puisqu'il ya que 33 100
milles à 330 mille habitants sur le sur
l'île et ça ne permettent pas si vous
voulez d'auto réguler l'économie
touristique et elle pèse très lourd
comme vous l'avez dit tout de suite au
début de vos propos donc ça aide pour
nous extrêmement difficile et je pense
qu'il faut se savoir raison garder et en
même temps quand ce disque il faut se
préparer pour l'avenir à condition qu'on
est je l'espère très vite trouver un
médicament dans l'urgence et du vaccin
dans un second temps en tout cas
beaucoup d'incertitude on l'aura compris
merci jean pierre pinelli vice président
du cercle des grandes maisons corses
d'avoir été avec nous pour vous exprimer
donc sur cette situation compliquée on
l'aura compris pour les restaurants les
hôtels les cafés français merci à vous